cinder blocks and car parts remain
scattered in a Las Vegas backyard after
a car went through a wall and into a
pool neighbors saying two people were
seen running from that car happened at a
home right by Mojave and University
Tuesday afternoon 8 news now reporter
Ryan Matthey shows us the damage
this Rubble once separated University
Avenue from the Thompson family backyard
until Tuesday a car slamming into the
backyard and landing in this 10-foot
deep pool leaving family and neighbors
questioning who did this
a white Kia suspended in mid-air this is
hours after police say they responded to
this intersection Tuesday afternoon
because of this car I was sitting in the
backyard and I had a big Screech and
then a big boof Danielle biller peeked
over her wall two doors down and saw
what she believed to be two teenage boys
running away so one of them was limping
so I said to him are you okay but he
ignored me and then he just kept running
down towards Pecos they weren't wearing
a seatbelt so they did what into the the
windshield this is Sandra Thompson's
dad's house she's house sitting just
worried about how my dad's gonna react
to it because he's got heart problems
and I like in a way to get tube anxiety
especially overseas I'm like worried
about his health while he's traveling
out of the country she's putting the
pieces back together we're obviously
worried about people going into the
backyard now because it's just wide open
and breaking in that way with holes in
the wall and car remnants in the pool
family neighbors and police are left
questioning what now I mean it could
have been my will that have been hit
damaging people's property that's they
have to take care of that and maybe not
be financially able to
police say as of this morning the two
people have not been identified no
injuries have been reported no word
either on who owns Zakia neighbors
believe that KIA may have been stolen